[Music]
everyone
I think you to shoot of course doesn't
fit me you want the real Avengers
don't mess with me cuz I've hurt
everybody in love I just got to do this
on my home
spider-man homecoming July 7th you're
young you don't understand how the world
works
stay close to the ground I know you
sneak out every night what is going on
with you treating me like a kid are you
already in what have you died tonight I
just got to do this on my own
spider-man homecoming you spot something
like that happening you run the other
way yeah cool so lose game new top know
you've seen that before you should
probably stop staring with Laurie it's
creepy though you're late
you guys are losers you did good but
this does not mean you're an Avenger
don't mess with me you just played her
man no I'm not I'm not
there's carob lucky because it's the
Hugh P surprise spider-man homecoming
listen Peter you did good but this does
not mean you're an Avenger you treat me
like a kid but you are a kid don't mess
with me you everybody
you have to catch this guy nothing's
gonna stop you Parker
my office so you got to tension how are
you gonna make things right
spider-man homecoming so to become an
Avenger are they like trials can't you
just be a friendly neighborhood
spider-man
none of this would have happened if you
would just listen to me
don't mess with everybody today that guy
is still out there I just got to do this
on my own
oh this is a cool thing
I keep the suit of course doesn't fit me
hey guys what's up get your PIN number
wait a minute you guys I'm the real
Avengers I can tell Hulk gives it away
hello you have 78
[Music]
whoa that was awesome spider-man don't
mess with everybody you want
and whatnot here we go
you know him to take me up
[Music]